I’m a third-generation Detroiter.
My grandmother moved to Detroit in 1936
during the Great Migration
and brought all
of her Southern ways with her.
She had an abundant garden
with flowers for butterflies
and honeybees and birds.
She preferred to take the bus
to Eastern Market
to purchase all of her meat
just to make sure that it was fresh.
She owned a home on Mendota Street
and knew that home ownership
would create wealth and opportunity
for her growing family.
My family's story is not
an unusual Detroit story,
and up until the late 1950s,
Detroit was a haven
for middle-class families
living in neighborhoods
where there was green space
and community connectivity
and opportunity.
But my grandmother's Detroit
is not the Detroit that I live in today.
The Detroit today is not sustainable.
84 percent of Detroiters
identify as Black or Latino,
and five percent are foreign-born.
That makes this not just
a climate and economic issue
but an equity issue.
And I know this
because I have spent my entire career
focused on the intersection
between race and poverty.
More recently, the work I do
with my colleagues
focuses on how climate impacts
neighborhoods and communities
that are isolated
from economic prosperity.
Being financially secure
and climate resilient
should be the most important priority
for communities across the country.
That is what I want to talk
with you about today.
Detroit is not generally
thought of as a city
that is at risk for climate impact,
but in fact it is.
We define resilience as places
where residents can have their needs met
and are free from long-term
chronic stress,
giving them the ability to withstand
and recover from acute shocks.
If you are financially stable,
then you are much more likely
to withstand and recover
from the acute shock of climate change.
Detroit's economic inequity
and climate vulnerability
began over 100 years ago
under the guise of innovation.
Detroit not only
led the way for automobiles
but manufacturing.
Manufacturing was a part
of our community fabric.
Industrial sites were nestled
in neighborhoods throughout the city
so that workers could walk
to their factory jobs.
Our economy was booming.
And although Detroit was not necessarily
equal across racial lines,
it was still a city of stable,
middle-class neighborhoods.
In 75 years,
our city went from a peak
population of 1.8 million
down to a population of 620,000 in 2022.
All of those sites
where there was manufacturing
and industrial sites that led
to our economic boom,
many of those industrial sites
stand vacant and abandoned.
We now have about 19 square miles
of vacant land in Detroit.
These industrial sites have led
to dangerous contamination,
both to our land
and our water and our air.
About two years ago,
eight inches of rain fell over Detroit
over a period of three days.
And not just Detroit,
but southeast Michigan.
Scientists describe this
as a more-than-500-year rain event.
Now, eight inches of rain
doesn't seem like a lot of rain,
but this one rain event
flooded our streets.
Basements became filled
with storm water and sewage.
The repair costs were insurmountable
for many families,
and with nearly half
of Detroiters renting,
it often led to homelessness.
Climate change exacerbates and compounds
economic inequity in our city.
But I believe there are three
things that we can do
to begin to change
the resilient future for Detroit.
First, we have to begin to create
an economic environment
in which all Detroiters can grow wealth.
Advanced technology
and tech-based businesses
are the fastest-growing industries
in Detroit, but also the nation.
It's these businesses that will contribute
to solving our climate dilemma
and make millions,
even billions, doing it.
But unless we include
Black and brown Detroiters,
both as workers
and investing in founders,
we will leave our largest
demographic out of our future.
Second, we have to stop only responding
when there’s a crisis situation,
like flooding and air quality control,
and begin to think about green
stormwater infrastructure
and solar and renewable
energy proactively.
I was having this
conversation with my sister
because that's what sisters do,
talk about manufacturing
and infrastructure investment.
This is my sister, I have two of them.
So she lives in Washington, DC.
Eight inches of rain, in her opinion,
was just not enough rain
to create that much flooding.
And she kind of didn't believe me
that Detroit was at risk
for climate impacts.
And I explained to her that Detroit
is not different from other cities
in its process for making municipal
investment decisions.
Municipal investment decisions
are made for primarily two ways:
new development and crisis repair.
Detroit is not unique.
What makes Detroit unique
is it has 100-year-old gray infrastructure
supporting 139 square miles of Detroit.
We can no longer only
make decisions for crisis.
We don't have that luxury.
We have to make decisions differently
to improve the quality
of life for Detroiters
and improve the quality
of the neighborhoods
that we're all living in for the future.
Finally, we have to begin
to invest in neighborhoods
so that they are free
from blight and deterioration.
As an urbanist and a futurist,
I want to help Detroiters imagine
the city they deserve to live in.
You shouldn't have to live in a suburb
to be surrounded by beautiful gardens,
parks and trees.
We can plant urban forests here.
(Applause)
So that we can reduce urban heat-island
impacts and improve air quality.
We can plant sustainable gardens
and food gardens
just like the ones
you are seeing on the screen,
that my team and community partners
have planted all over Detroit.
We can do this.
We have to do this.
And we need to do this
because investing in neighborhoods,
not just as a social program,
but we must do this
because climate equity
and climate economics
require investment
in order to see the actual results.
This is true, not only
in this nation's largest Black city,
but in every city
where inequality is on the rise
and climate equity will surely follow.
My grandmother's house still stands on
Mendota long after she passed away.
Her expectation of me and of you
is that a Black family just like mine
that migrated north 90 years ago
will be able to prosper 90 years from now
because they are economically thriving.
Their neighborhood has parks, gardens,
trees and community spaces.
And they are still Black.
Thank you.
(Applause)